well it's official the GOP convention is
heading to the Sunshine State this
summer the RNC unanimously deciding to
scale down convention plans in Charlotte
North Carolina in host the celebratory
aspects in Jacksonville Florida
including the president's acceptance
speech here with what this means for his
great city Jacksonville mayor
lynnie curry good morning to you mr.
mayor good morning what's your reaction
what do you make of being chosen as the
place where this will happen well we're
grateful it's going to be here we were
able to demonstrate the ability to put
together and put on an event in a safe
responsible way as we emerge from kovat
19 we we we were responsible during the
pandemic we came out of it with we
flatten the curve pretty quickly over
time our hospitalizations are low we
demonstrated a month ago that we can put
on events we're not going to operate out
of fear we're gonna operate out of data
science and get people back to work in a
responsible way and that's what this
convention is now I have to ask you
mayor you are seeing a rise a spike in
cases in Florida what is your reaction
particularly should this continue to be
the case
well we're testing we've got a number of
testing sites up we we were one on the
front end of testing when the pandemic
started we've continued to add but we
recall when this all started all the
experts told us the goal is flatten the
curve protect the hospital of health
systems without a vaccine the viruses
with us we've done that in Jacksonville
we've done that in Florida our
hospitalizations are low we watched that
daily we're gonna have to learn to live
with this fire and virus in a
responsible way take care of those that
are most likely to to get it and end up
with symptoms and in the hospital but we
got to get people back to work and we've
been doing that now for weeks working
with our governor and we're gonna put on
a big event and have a major economic
impact for our businesses mr. mayor I
don't want to put you on the spot but I
have a very interesting question having
covered a lot of conventions this one
will be unlike any other but do you do
you anticipate seeing people with mass
wearing masks
what look this is eight to ten weeks out
so whatever the protocols are then we
will will have them in place to make
sure people are safe we're gonna have
temperature checks but go back just a
month and a half two months ago there
were experts saying there would be no
sports this summer of the fall there
were experts saying theme parks wouldn't
be reopened and that stuff's happening
now so if our trends continue we we are
we've have been headed the right
direction as we phase out reopening 'z
we expect to have a full arena in
celebrate the reen ama nation of
president Trump you say a lots happening
listen you've got the GOP convention and
I even saw captain sandy from below deck
but a hundred and six year old firehouse
building is Jacksonville v place to be
in America right now it is the place to
be yes I met with her yesterday we've
got major economic boom development
happening that started before the
pandemic and people are ready to get
moving she bought an old firehouse she's
gonna do some cool stuff there including
a restaurant also she's got a great idea
the way that our River sets the depth of
it were one of the few cities where you
could bring a super yacht in and
actually get it out of the water if you
need to for four purposes so all right
we're on the move come to Jacksonville
all right be safe Thank You mayor linen
curry appreciate your time sir thank you